I was curious a couple of questions
first
are you considering raising a family in
the coming years okay and you know we
earlier on this semester we studied
Warren Buffett and and you know that the
the dynasty of the Buffett's and I
really wanted to ask you if you know
with with you or with you or treasure
and with your experience and and and
with your inheritance as well were you I
mean what would you do for we because
within the Buffett's day he is not he
will not he will not be having his
children inherit very much money and and
so I was curious what would you do for
your for your children would you would
you want them to create a life of their
own and and build their dynasty or would
and and donate most of your treasure to
philanthropic philanthropic means or
would you want to pass on large you know
a large chunk of your of your treasure
to your children to build a foundation
or what what's an advice your goal
that's totally we're like right I'm sure
in smiling over there
we're completely like having these
conversations and I think that the first
and most important thing and this is one
thing that I love with working with my
mom is the the best thing that kids can
inherit is sort of the moral compass
kind of that your parents give you and
your sense your worldview kind of
obviously it's your own worldview but
it's very much shaped by what your
parents tell you and teach you and so
you know that I think is what we want to
emphasize in our family is that create a
culture of inquiry create a culture of
responsibility but not of pressure
around those things because I don't
think you know like if my children don't
grow up to be philanthropist that's
perfectly fine and they
should grow up to be whoever they want
to be and so I'm not sure that it's a
good idea to embed in a financial plan
kind of almost like you shall you shall
run a foundation and it shall be
involved in strategic philanthropy and
like you know what I mean so I think
that it's an ongoing dialogue but the
first thing I think that we plan on
doing is involving our kids in our
giving so what are the things you know
what are the things that they care about
how can they see that engaging in these
causes can make a difference I think
that's important